[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
bon tu connais que ça c'est une fille
avec des grosses pierres une wii ça
c'est l'original très attention avec
lunettes blanches à la poule dar el
chapo boulin
d'où curtis mais fait tout devrait pas
trouver ça c'est évidemment c'est par où
lyon six insurgés auront lieu
c'est faux vrais pièges stomie qu'il a
fait c'était l'amérique chez nous un
wallonne la la j'ai la version originale
non ça oui ouais bah oui ça c'est pour
toi
bienne millar la grande sarah les années
80 c'est moi qui souffre toujours de la
glace que j'allais jouer même si les
machins la magie c'est à son nom il va
dit
alors
4e étage magie bon sabrina simmons vraie
vie pour toi parce que je sais que ça
craquait dessus quand on sait qu'en
dessous
les musiciens c'est une bande de petits
web et les ventes de mettre noir qui
dansait à l'époque de ce
du palace de naître j'adore je les adore
face à face à des merlus restent les
seuls
masseglia à huy
et comme tu me donnes sirech combien j
un ticket d'entrée simple août
si grâce à des nazis arnaud alors elle
pas très violent mais pas tu fais
maintenant on la ressent jour ça va ça
va pas mal c'est lui carlos et c'est
bien votre carlos yip man savage a dit
carlos en mai on est en train de faire
de la tête sous le nez c'est guy martin
du mont sutton santé oms en descente je
vous félicite et si moi je suis pas
gastro suis pas très à l'est dans des
restos gastro mais qu'est ce que c'est
bon ce que vous faites ça va ouais ça va
bien et c'est franchement bien c'est
sympa non soudain l'harmonie des quatre
des gens se régale sa bravoure vois
jouer je vais tomber très attention
attention
mais un jour soit moins tu veux morsi du
blender 8 me tester les valeurs sûres du
blind test
ok ça roule mais il joue aussi bah ouais
tu sais le rôle qu'ont joué moi je vous
précède un guide passionné alors carlos
savoie carlos fisher ça il est très bien
obama nous allons envoyer vraiment un
mec classe ainsi vous qu est-ce qu
qu'est ce qu'on va manger à la sauce va
donc ce soir le thème et rouge
ouais donc on entrait ya les petits
rouget de roche ont essayé bêche et
après carlo c'est quoi et après on a
l'eau marotti dans sa carapace avec un
coulis de poivron rouge du tout va bien
son petit frère thomas donc cédé homard
breton juste heureux dit que ça et puis
c'est la fin des poivrons rouges ils
sont vraiment bien et puis on dessert
nous avons nécessaire en à le lan -
jouffre aise
ah j'adore le blanc manger c'est génial
c'est génial c'est un
c'est qu'ils font ça alors vous avez
fait oublier vraiment la merde c'est qui
la rend il a succédé à raymond olive
avec april l'angem un petit show kart
wii n'avait pas oublié il est toujours
là mais c'est vrai la cuisine a évolué
mais il est toujours présent il ya
toujours c'est son âme qui planait c'est
une cuisine d'aujourd'hui 1
c'est une cuisine d'aujourd'hui une
cuisine vivante vous avec x vous avez
quad et combien d'étoilés trois étoiles
encore trois étoiles reste pour ça je
voulais faire mon service ça vous fait
flipper ça parce que l'eau puis s'est
suicidé quand même assez mais c'est
énormément marqué une pression il ya une
pression mais il ya énormément de
moments de bonheur mais c'est le
cuisinier à ce niveau là on est sur le
fil toujours on a écorché vif donc
on peut vite basculer il faut vraiment
c'est un animateur télé quoi ya de la
pression mais ne peut qu ici sinon ces
dépressions nerveuses un arrêt seriez là
parce que problème de la télé c'est un
peu comme vous c'est à dire le problème
c'est quand on réussit on gagne que le
droit de rester c'est vraiment ça se
gagne quoi tu viens me dois de rester et
tu fais une émission qui marche on dit
super beau navet prochaine c'est tout on
donne pas il donne pas deux fois plus
d'argent et on te dit oui bah vous
revenir les prochaines et vous c'est un
peu pareil enfin nous c'est un peu
profonds cherché à faire c'est rester
c'est comme un cheval de rodéo quoi vous
cherchez à rester sur le cheval d'euros
dénoncer ça c'est ça mais bon il ya
tellement de bonheur mais c'est vrai qu
on est trois étoiles mais ça dure pas de
vitam aeternam c'est vrai qu'on est
champion olympique qui peut dire vingt
ans que j'étais olympique en 68 20 15 46
ça va je fais deux jeunes 1 c'est votre
bouche durringer tant dégradée boucard
plus récemment chez hachette livre la
regarde ne finit pas la vrai javou comm
cuisine en attendant cette cuisine moi
j'ai jamais fait beaucoup la cuisine à
temps si tu veux c'est eux qui la font
et je dois être ferme et déjà regarder
la couleur quand même donc c'est hervé
tullet qui a fait les illustrations
parce que je suis passionné de peinture
de photographies et l'idée c'était de
faire 50 recettes inspirées de 50
photographies que j'aime bien du monde
entier a besoin spider oui si ça vous
inspirer d c'est un truc qu'on renvoie
ça vous inspire et de visuels pour faire
des recettes chez tout c'est la même
démarche
après je les je les dessine elles sont
elles sont réalisées il fait comme il
les a dans la tête il est des signes
signifie recettes réalisées ouais après
y'a plus qu'à la faire techniquement en
cuisine
le plus gros est fait et vous inventez
la recette par la forme avant de lui
après aprilia plus que le réglage
comment une voiture un petit peu de
sport en règle mais en général ça c'est
quoi le truc le plus dingue objet d
inventaire entre la glace au petit pois
très clair ces petits pois et joue la
france et banks a offert un dîner vers
la sortie mais il faut que ce soit au
printemps de présence parce qu'il fait
une petit pot de la rose et là vous
allez dire combien de temps un bruit si
là vous savez que les vingt-sept dîner à
faire quand même
on va l'essayer 27 couleurs ouais on va
trouver way pens est le même pour nos
intérêts sont déjà agent rick son entrée
au prix conseillé alors 4e étage
4e la nourriture c'est un moment de
plaisir c'est un moment de bonheur c'est
plus on partage on est assez la même
table je suis d'accord avec lui quand
même le viennent de vivre une drôle
drôle de pression car bah ouais euh la
maintenance hélas hélas c'est l'enfer
les mecs qui sont terrorisés de perdre
une jupe à pois hilton étoiles vous avez
deviné un jour avec nous ici ouais je
les jours en tout cas si vous n'êtes pas
un soir c'est un drame non c'est pas un
drame mais je fais ce que je veux mais
j'ai moi je trouve que notre place est
là bas où j'ai pas besoin de ce lycée va
très bien ces messieurs c'est pour eux
c'est bon laurent grenadine en sang ça
va ah oui très bien est ce magnifique un
gîte mexes à la bombe ou un cours
bonsoir c'est le mystère je vais essayer
ouais c'est toi bonsoir bonsoir soit
cardoso carlos voix guy martin du grand
véfour voilà mes invités laurent voulzy
elie semoun en fait on a fait les frais
en fait je connais pas bien bon dit on
va vous laisser aller à l'écossé à merci
en tout cas vous allez voir vous allez
l'adorer nous appeler c'est un souci
vous raccompagne non mais tout va bien
je vais vous dire franchement pas
comment ça va les deux l'a déjà fait la
première partie à l'olympia non mais je
veux aussi lui qui a fait mal aux yeux
j'ai fait deuxième partie ouais ouais
non mais c'était c'était vraiment ça
s'est passé mais je crois que c'est moi
je savais qu'ils chantaient et on
s'était déjà rencontré il avait fait
écouter des chansons qui les fait que
j'avais trouvé vraiment bien quand même
puis est venu voir son passé j'étais
flatté d'ailleurs qu'ils viennent me
voir pour le propos fait régresser
chanson est le seul truc qui m'a dit
d'ailleurs il avait pas tellement de
d'états d'âme là dessus m'a simplement
dit il ya des gens qui trouvent que
c'est un peu un peu bizarre de faire une
carrière comme je fais de faire des
sketches de faire un comique entre
guillemets et et et voilà et moi je dis
ça m'étonne pas parce que effectivement
c'est ce qui me paraît le plus difficile
quand on veut faire de la chanson peut
faire n'importe quoi avant le plus dur à
mon avis c'est d'être entre guillemets
comique acteur une surtout dans les
dents genre sketches et de passer après
des chansons on dirait deux univers
différents mais en même temps je lui dit
fonce parce que c'est celle ci cette
botte de le faire faut y aller parce
qu'il m'a fait écouter des chansons et
j'ai trouvé vraiment bien quoi donc j'ai
trouvé que c'était alors quand est
arrivée sur scène les gens ils
comprenaient pas pourquoi vous prenez
pas trop fascinant c'était marqué quand
c'est moi qui avais demandé aux
olympiens way laurent avait demandé
elie semoun chante ce qu'elles aient pas
vues
tu vois il ya une sorte de
de bruissements dans la salle qu'est-ce
qui fait et puis non mais je les ai mis
à l'aise tu vois je peux je me suis mis
à l'aise moi aussi tu vois en même temps
en disant trois conneries je me souviens
que le premier soir il ya quelqu'un qui
est arrivé en retard
tu vois qui a dérangé tout le monde
alors j'ai mis qu'un matt walsh aurait
allumé à l'époque où je suis jamais été
commis chanteur je ne fais pas chier ces
bonbons fabrazyme quand même place toi
pour moi ton petit pied j'essaie de me
mettre à l'aise et puis après dès la
première chanson les gens étaient ils
ont écouté religieusement je voulais
faire avec vous le dis parce que je
pense que la confiance
bah oui bien sûr et puis surtout
non parce que je les aime et puis parce
que parce que je les adore et puis parce
que je me sens proche
en toute modestie de de ton univers quoi
moi j'aime bien d'or et chansons d'amour
les chansons sentimentales
j'adore sa voix enfin je me sens proche
de lui j'aurais pas fait la première
partie de j'ai pas de hélène ségara j'ai
rien contre elle mais je me sens pas de
faire partie de cette famille musicale
mtv ya pas d ya plus d'émissions tu peux
chanter aujourd'hui pas trop non si j'ai
chanté chez drucker chez sarah qui n'ont
proposé non ouais ouais je sais pas si
cette affaire c'est toi j'ai fait oui
l'avion s'est posé des questions mais je
me suis posée mais extrêmement longtemps
puisque la preuve la preuve la première
année de star academy ou mail proposé de
le faire j'ai pas voulu le faire et la
deuxième année qui est de star académie
voir proposer de le faire et là ça a été
des pourparlers à n'en plus finir et
finalement j'ai fait je les fais alors
bon on parvenir cdd c'était des
discussions même sur l'éthique c'est que
ça de faire star academy ou pas star
académie c'est un problème d'éthique
quoi est-ce qu'il faut cautionner cette
émission ou pas ses salles près c'est ça
la grande histoire
donc j'ai des discussions n'en plus
finir avec d'autres chanteurs et aussi
avec évidemment avec ma maison me disent
que la maison de disque que je pense que
c'est bien de le faire avec mon
entourage ma famille me
ma chérie enfin les des gens qui
m'entourent les gens des amis et tous on
parle de star académie et c'est est il
devenu une obsession pour moi parce que
je sais alors c'était un pas l'air
d'aller non je suis en train de
réfléchir j'ai la pression il faut que
je fasse star academy et dauphine a
décidé c'est quoi ce qui m'a décidé
c'est un c'était j'étais parti pour
vraiment pas le faire je respecte les
gens qui ne font pas ce qui m'a décidé
s'il ya eu quand même une grosse
pression de la maison de disques et de
personnes de mon entourage
il ya les missions et les candidats les
gens qui vont je n'ai aucun jugement sur
les gens qui vont chez moi quand j'étais
petit j'ai fait des j'ai passé des
auditions de maisons dit je me suis fait
jeter des vous amuser c'était pas mal je
suis allée faire des crochets ça me
réveille n'est pas sur la place mallet
habib un crochet ce soir il va parleurs
qui était passé ce soir prochain grand
crochet sur la place du marché mais
méritée vas-y mes copains et vas-y tu
sûr tu vas gagner et où j'y suis allé
j'ai gagné en plus il chantait quoi
mettre de cheveux de chansons c'était
j'étais tout j'étais j'avais 16 ans 17
ans ou 10 17 ans et j'ai chanté deux
chansons que j'avais composé quand même
timide timide c'est à dire c'est pas une
fois sans que ça peut être
timide oui oui oui timide ça elle ne
parle jamais sauf quand tu es le murmure
elle ne serait jamais qu'en baissant les
yeux
si seulement elle était un peu moins
timide
j'oserais lui parler devant elle je
serai moins stupide c'est une petite
bosse assez bon bref j'ai gagné donc les
candidats le désactiver à l'époque quand
j'avais 17 ans on m'aurait dit yann
émission de télé leurs effets je ne sais
pas parce qu'il ya c'est quand même un
reality show faut être dans la dans le
dortoir et tous - sous la douche en même
temps j'aurais peut-être fait tu crois
que les futurs cabrel les futurs goldman
il irait à cette émission gens qui
savent quelque chose que soit sa colère
il répond ouais je les trouve bien
stéréotypé quoi sainte non mais attends
ils sont allés chez les minis lara
fabian des lignes c'est ça on voyait
arriver dès des gamines qui voulait
chanter du céline durval que l'adjoint
j'en ai parlé avec henri salvador
j'ai rencontré à l'émission la top of
the pop le rhin lui m'a dit rien star
academy jamais c'est de la merde et tout
lui fera jamais il ya des gens qui sont
hyper je respecte je vois j'ai compris
parce que les armes les arguments qui me
donne est
et musikwelle est complètement changé
désolé moi j'ai discuté des arguments
pendant des nuits tout simplement les
arguments d'henri salvador
non mais je les comprends mais ça tu
l'avais dit après c'est vrai mais là il
regarde ses fiches nous aider son fils
s'en fiche 1-1 alors affirmé page était
alors 4e un peu sombre boire
et
le reçoit
mené à rien sur site
c'est
je peux
m
q
je
vous savez
mais là tu veux six mois alors on va
jouer attention à la marche
oui vous vous connaissez presque bien on
a très bien mais presque pas reconnaître
celui que tu le fais je connais
bizarrement très bien commencé en fait
c'est devenu enfin on a collaboré
d'artistes sinon c'est un îlot donne un
coup de pouce à dire non mais c'est vrai
ça doit 90 91 4 en moins
ils sont d'une boîte mais oui tu as
partagé tu les fais pas c'est vrai moi
tu meurs il n'a pas tellement changé mon
temps j'ai eu 40 ans et à 3 jours
ac toi oui c'est donc à 40 ans et qui
j'ai dit ok c'est bon ça y est quoi je
suis pas un c'est bizarre tu vas un peu
de champagne
si vous êtes ensemble dans la vie où
vous êtes arrivés ensemble et qui n'ont
cédé hasard je suis arrivé en bas il est
arrivé en bas non mais c'est pas mon
style de femme à bord s'ils répondent
pascal mais sa peur je n'apprécie pas eu
d'euphorie que je vois pas d'alcool moi
à t comme tous les soirs je sens bien je
vois là bas alors on est mort c'est vrai
que j'ai une pierre calcul en plus oui
c'est ça qui est difficile à gérer mais
bon ça va je me suis bien entraîné
basquin bien dd c'est une pro là mais
j'avoue que c'est jouissif tous les
soirs de jouer quelqu'un de d'un peu
feuilles après de très très bourg et
donc ça fait une heure dix ans je suis
quand même un peu ma baignoire quoi
buvait pas on boit des jouets ont déjà
un peu mon bois des trucs dans l'ivresse
des acteurs ils jouent les bois où ils
boivent pas et je peux le dire pour pas
casser la magie et voilà c'est le
plateau alors il ya qui jonchaient le
dernier mois christian sinniger mais
qu'est ce qu'on voit toujours le point
et tu la connais c'est en plus je n'ai
pas de pouvoir
82 donc ça fait vingt
un de 20 ans donc c'est vrai que sur
scène ya une vraie alchimie non s'amuse
vraiment et des fous rires enfin c est
ce gênant de reprendre une pièce qui a
déjà tellement joué comme ça t'en sers
avec dernier je l'espère une fois tout
seul une fois que balasko pour voir un
peu le clou à la vu jouer oui bien sûr
eu deux fois deux fois pouvoir le coup
leur créativité qui me restait bon ça va
quelque chose qu'il a ok il n'a pas
touché dans lequel je peux encore
trouver des voies des choses un peu
drôle émouvante et savait j'avoue que
[Musique]
sais je
oui petit feu
ce soit
je
[Musique]
toi tu es là
bonsoir vous êtes quand de stéphane da
est effectivement thiam et on en est on
monte ici
la rapide hélyce et voilà
me connaissez
alors le portable se met à droite ou à
gauche des couteaux bon allez alors la
vôtre mes amis nous aime juste pour quel
train parce que tu es content d'être à
côté de laurent boutonnat
[Musique]
mais je laime d'amour ça se comprend
très bien
depuis des années on se connaît on se
connaît depuis longtemps mais mais je
n'ai pas un gars quelque chose de très
spécial chez laurent qui fait qu'il est
très touchant et que l'on regarde au
fond de ce score et qu'on l'enlève plus
jamais que ce que les familles dans leur
antre de chez toi là c'est la sûreté la
soirée on souffre sur chaque envie de
chanter non c'est grâce à lui que je
chante je vais te raconter un truc de
dingue
personne ne cessa mais un jour laurent
est venu dîner à la maison et j'étais
avec un petit copain d'antan qui je ne
suis plus au temps qui vous est de la
musique commence et donc à un moment il
s'est mis au piano il s'est mis à jouer
et puis
il se souvenait plus des paroles de sa
chanson donc j'ai commencé à fredonner
sa chanson et leur enveloppe touchante
pas mal c'est pas mal et tout bon le
dîner se termine
tu connais par coeur
parce que c'est ce que m'a dit henri
salvador
quand j'ai été le voir et c'est à cause
de ça que j'ai fait un album avant le
dîner se termine jean talon et parce que
l'on dit aux chanteurs et chanteuses
inquiète donc laurent 120 et moi je me
couchais mon mec il a un peu bougé de
m'avoir entendu chanter ce que comme je
suis un peu timide j'avais jamais chanté
devant lui et le lendemain matin au
petit déjeuner sur mon assiette il y
avait un cd et c'est la première chanson
qui m'offrait et c'est avec cette
chanson j'ai commencé mon album donc
lors on ne le sait pas mais c'est
vraiment je vais l'ombre pendant deux
déclenchent grâce à laurent qui a eu un
déclencheur et j'ai pu me lancer dans
cet album que je rêvais de faire depuis
les années d'âge de thé le mec qui t'as
écouté la chanson s'il y avait un public
tout le monde à peu dire
elisa tôt
et à l'opposé je peux vous voyez c'est
sûr je vous ai entendu j'étais entendu
sûr parce que je maintenant que c'est le
chanteur j'ai fait la table à l'élection
et l'attenté faut donc je vois j'écoute
tout et je t'ai entendu donc sur rfm et
le gars te disais et pourquoi est ce que
tu te remets toujours en question tu te
souviens de cette question je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui utiliser l'auto dérision
dans un métier comme celui ci c'est la
moindre des politesses
la faute à la chambre que mais ça a
commencé avec la chanson ce n'est que
moi ouais voilà tu vois ça a commencé
avec ce n'est que moi oui oui parler de
lui dans une chanson vous avez géré
cette ce recul assez c'est ce qui a dans
ton album actuel points non non c'est
pas y'a pas que ça mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya dans un média sa part du brouillard
des voix voilà je fais pour être vu ça
c'est parce que tu n'ont même pas ce que
c'est normal tu fais tes néant qu'à 20
et 49 comme toi comme moi c'est quand tu
commences à avoir cinquante quatre
balles et 55 balais d'intérêt à prendre
du recul t'as pas intérêt à prendre les
choses au premier degré parce que sinon
on a vu arriver la mort comme ça tu
essaies tu dis à ces petites
vieillissante est obligé de faire ça
noir froid génère de la mêlée bot comme
son fou maintenant ils attachent une
maison et me sens plus non non je
l'avais acheté non j'ai pas qu'il a dit
ça mais ça va j'ai vu moi j'ai vu écrit
dans jointe avait acheté une maison il
ya
c'est une vraie bonne idée je dessine je
suis pas sûr que maintenant c'est les
bras du thon catalogue éditorial à bmg
pour t'acheter une maison ibisa non
c'est pas vrai au cul la turbine à gaz
j'ai demandé mon catalogue éditorial
j'ai pas acheté de m'évader ça c'est
dingue je trouve sublime
j'en ai marre d'être con donc voilà j'ai
ses fruits lassé pourra bien sûr un
tournage
j'aurais pas osé tout s'est tu fais quoi
c'est un film avec marion cotillard qui
est une fille géniale et un film de
lucile hadzihalilovic répète du sida
mais je me sois rémission mais si la
deuxième but et donc ça s'appelle
l'école va mal tourner ça en belgique et
j'ai encore une journée de tournage au
mois de décembre
donc tu gardes les choses comme avant
voilà comme ça moi j'essaye de m'y
habitue voilà c'est la réalisatrice qui
a voulu que tu étais ça m'a fait rire
parce qu'on ne couper les cheveux j'ai
une frange en fait je suis très strictes
comme ça ouais et en fait donc on
coupait side et non plus comme ça que je
les regardais je suis black un domaine
en fait on m'a mise à la maman j'ai
tamise à son image assez drôle souvent
le beau temps c'est nouveau ça se
transpose dans un communiqué on était
deux avec marion n'a pas choisi michou a
dit marion elle a souffert aussi point
de vue pratique avec des blacks alors je
sens que j'ai souffert tant que média
pêcher à l'est dont ça c'était pour
enfants la tulipe
toi tu t'es bien dans le film n'a pas
aimé j'adorais ce nom c'est pas que j'ai
aimé ou pas et mais moi j'en ai vu
besson madame entrée 40 minutes j'ai
regardé je trouve ça plutôt bien foutu
mais
non ça pas très vite très bien marché
sap a été la bonne idée d'envoyer à
cannes moi je pensais que c'était génial
on était dans une arène ont fait casser
à katyn populaire ainsi l'asie mais les
spécialistes le disent d'ailleurs les
spécialistes c'est parti tout cas la
photo est belle c'est une bonne idée de
l'avoir inversé comme ça moi j'ai trouvé
aussi que c'était un randonneur numéro d
c'est la 5 en duo avec à prima bien sûr
c'est un mannequin la fille sur la photo
c'est une amie achats en fait c'est ma
femme à cette infâme sur la les
spécialistes pourraient
ce sont nos pays de nos mondes
les spécialistes présents
ce sens
qui de nos jours
les spécialistes présents ou un passé le
temps que je passais le penser
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'on me dit elle ils me
disent d'abord j'ai trouvé les chiffres
ridicules
au début ils m'ont dit tiens toi tu es
assis on en a vendu 3 194 des ternes
c'est quoi ça c'est pourri avec les
cassettes on en vend genre dit milou
fois ci c'est une folie et donc la
moyenne la des ventes c'est 3500 par
semaine a baissé un peu mais bien dans
ce tarif là ça va 100 milles au mois de
janvier
c'est bien mais lui il est là avec ce
qu'il a mangé les scores oui c'est ça va
s'habituer à ce titre et non déboussolé
qui fait 2 millions d'albums au début de
la fin pour le diesel
annie mais dites vous
de là
j'en veux
c'est bien comme il est
laissons ce que ça dit ce que tu as dit
à leurs premiers 500 la semaine une
cadence normale quoi ah ouais mais les
potes de reconnexion le disque j'avais
fait avant j'avais fait 5 45 tours à
voir en collectionne un parent est il le
dernier que j'ai fait j'avais vendu 545
disque au total peut cumuler tous
cumulés quand tu as eu le total des
royautés c'était j'ai la feuille encore
545 disques vendus et au total tu
connais loin des mais alors quand ils
eurent collectionne un jour j'arrive
dans le bureau du du bon ça reste ça
m'est arrivé qu'une fois mais j'arrive
dans le dans le bureau du patron de bmg
art il avait sa pipe c'était françois
dakhla alors je lui dis il me dit fais
que ça roule rockollection âge ferry 10
m'attendais 90000 ce matin ça n'arrive
qu'une fois dans ma vie à dire il y
avait des canal journée monstrueuse quoi
un journée ouais dans la journée 90000
incroyable ouais mais bon c'est des
trucs exceptionnel quoi manière pour les
ont poussés dans ton dernier album la
première chanson de thé fait c'était
estime qu'au monde en fait
bah oui c'est fou ça c'est à dire il a
rencontré un mec s'appelait joseph
wresinski un smiley qui tue le mec qui a
fondé atd quart monde
on a été les 40 il lui est demandé une
chanson élue de niveau mais je voulais
faire je vous le faire une chanson un
jour il a appris que le mec était mort
sans doute déjà bien réelle sanction
s'est senti un peu coupable je vais
essayer de résumer je fais une émission
de télé à noël que je n'avais pas envie
de faire
j'ai envie de passer noël avec eux deux
enfants on me propose cette émission de
télé on me l'a présenté franchement je
vous dis bon aller au palais des congrès
et doux le soir le 24 décembre au soir
je vais pas y aller et puis alors même
bon
l'attaché de presse à la maison de 10
mais si c'est sympa et ça mais ne dit
pas et me dit c'est l'émission de télé
quoi
puis bon j'y vais alors j'appelle je dis
bon magie et aux enfants je dis à ma
femme à l'époque je suis dit mais coutu
dit à julien nicolas que j'arriverai
qu'à minuit parce que les missions
durent jusqu'à 11h30 ips et j'arrive
là-bas et c'est au palais des congrès et
tout le public c'était des gens moi je
connaissais pas on me dit voilà tu vas
chanter à la répétition dit tu vas
chanter devant des gens qui sont qui
font partie d'un mouvement qui s'appelle
add quart monde qui sont des gens qui
sont vives dans la misère en france et
je vois ces gens dans la salle et je
suis très très touché et après le après
l'émission ce que c'est une émission de
télé au palais des congrès il ya un
monsieur qui vient me voir un petit
monsieur qui vient me voir et me dit
voilà je suis père joseph wrésinski
jeudi on m'a parlé de vous tout à
l'heure une serre la main tout et puis
me dit vous savez ce que vous allez
faire vous allez faire une osé écrire
une chanson pour nous pour les gens qui
ont enfin pas pour nos voisins et pour
eux
non non non pour eux pour les gens qui
pour les gens qui sont dans la misère
enfermés dans le monde alors je suis dit
oui vous les avez vues dans la salle
chauffée oui je dit écoutez franchement
je crois que je vais pas le faire les
choses je suis dit écoutez bon il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de chansons qui
sont faites pour des causes et tout ça
il faut vraiment être investis il faut
lever le poing en disant je suis contre
la guerre contre la misère contre les
pauvres entre les racistes contre je dis
franchement c'est pas très dur pour le
faire sans âme
c'est pas très très dur et il faut être
un fou de légitimer pour ça et puis tu
me savais toujours la main il me disait
vous allez le faire et en fait il m'a
dit je vous lâche pas alors il m'a
envoyé un courrier trois semaines après
j'ai reçu une lettre et je réponds pas
et un an après 1 an et deux ans
maintenant
un an et demi ou deux ans après cet
homme meurt j'apprends ça j'étais avec
alain en train d'écrire des chansons
vous mettez les infos le soir à moi je
regarde non alain souchon jacques et je
regardais et je regardais à la télé puis
juge après je vois joseph wrésinski min
puis je sais pas un truc et on met en
même temps j'y pensais des fois je dis
mais c'est dingue ce que j'ai pas
rappelé monsieur puis petit à petit j'ai
pris contact avec le mouvement et puis
j'ai voulu les rencontrer tout ça et
puis voilà et puis et puis j'ai donc
j'ai fait l'album et voilà aider à dix
ans après à la trinité un soir avec à
l'insouciance je dis autrement j'ai une
commande
il me dit c'est quoi la commande d'une
saison n'est parlée atd quart monde de
faire un vrai inscrits qui m'a passé une
commande ya dix ans un fils aimant et et
dit à une idée de musique et j'avais
commencé une musique une mule sur un ton
il me dit ben c'est bien et je le vois
commencé à écrire quoi
et puis il commence à écrire en fait il
commence à écrire le premier couplet à
minuit on arrive à cette chanson qui dit
qui est devenu jésus et il commence à
écrire les couplets et j'avais donc ce
début de musique et je commence à
chanter avec la guitare et lui chante en
même temps que moi et un moment où
monsieur à wells très bizarre mais bon
un moment enfin nous ça nous a beaucoup
marqué un moment ils devaient être je
sais pas peut-être deux heures du matin
on chantait la chanson il y avait déjà
de deux couplets écrit +1 le début d'un
frein on chante est arrivé à je sais pas
à 45 secondes au 50 secondes dans la
chanson moi ça me paraît étrange mais je
sens de la glace sur moi un froid alors
qu'il y avait un feu de cheminée
je sens un froid sur moi mais de la
placer quoi j'ai la chair de poule et
les larmes aux yeux je sais pas pourquoi
et je continue à chanter de sapia la
chanter en même temps quoi puisqu'il
disait le texte lu moi je rappe et est
le disent eux-mêmes et jeudi alain c'est
bizarre j'ai senti un moment au moment
où tu as dit ce mot là j'ai senti de la
glace sur moi partout mais me dit c'est
bizarre ce que tu me dis parce que mme
au même moment où tu me lis ça j'ai
senti que j'étais complètement j'allais
très bizarre je dis parce que ça m'a
beaucoup marqué en fait je pars du
principe qu'on ne sait rien mais qu'on
peut avoir l'intuition de dumont savoir
quoi ah bah oui mais diodio constat
[Musique]
john bâtés que satan
quelle est la chose quelle est la chose
la plus irréelle que tu ai vu qui t'a
vraiment à tout à l'heure tu disais j'ai
eu le sens de glace et en disant un mot
j'ai vraiment les expériences comme ça
c'est énorme
non mais moi je suis je m'intéresse au
rêve par exemple - et en fait il ya des
rêves
c'est comme dans la vie quoi le monde du
rêve pour moi c'est un monde absolument
immense il ya des rêves qui correspond
qui répondent qu'ils sont analysable
qu'on peut mettre dans lesquels on peut
avec les on peut avoir une clé pour les
décoder il a fait des rêves
prémonitoires
oui j'ai rêvé que j'étais au bord d'un
j'étais au bord d'un canal la nuit et
qu' il y avait une haie qui était devant
moi et j'ai alors je rêve je dit oui
j'ai rêvé trois nuits de suite
il y avait une haie et quand je passais
mon nez au-dessus de l'oeil
il y avait un canal et le canal était au
dessus de ce niveau de la terre on va
dire qu'il y avait une but comme ça et
que la surface de l'eau était au dessus
du niveau de la terre et je voyais l'urd
une ville et je voyais un avion qui
tombait sur cette ville trois nuits de
suite et ça m'effrayait j ch et d'un
check avions reçu trajet bond de 3 nuls
2 3 jours plus tard il ya un 747 qui
s'est écrasé sur amsterdam
ouais or je veux rien que quinze jours
avant tu as rêvé
qu' il ya eu une catastrophe nucléaire
cette catastrophe nucléaire n'a pas eu
lieu
et tu t'en souviens plus de ce rêve tu
t'en souviens uniquement parce que deux
jours plus tard il ya eu un avion qui
s'est écrasé il ya très très longtemps
j'étais donc adolescents
ma mère est morte quand j'avais 11 ans
donc j'étais adolescent j'étais dans le
métro et c'était l'époque c'est quand l
ado tu parle à tout le monde tu fais le
coût etc
je vois une femme et je lui dire vous
êtes très belle madame à merci vous êtes
gentil c'était dans un bus en fait on
prend le bus on se quitte comme ça au
revoir madame gelard rencontre dans le
métro je m'assois à côté d'elle et elle
me dit ah vous souvenez enfin je me
souviens de nous mutuellement elle
m'invite à prendre un café
chose bizarre parce qu'on se connaît ni
d'ève ni d'adam on commence à parler etc
elle me fait raconter ma vie et je lui
dis bah voilà j'ai perdu ma mère quand
j'avais 11 ans à bon d'accord elle était
prof de français à moi aussi je suis
prof de français fin je l'était en
algérie à jeudi assez marrant parce que
ma mère était est né en algérie à
tlemcen
ah bon à tlemcen ah oui d'accord mais
comment elle s'appelait votre mère jeudi
denise mannequin s'était souvent jeunes
filles et là il se met à pleurer
elle me dit ah mais j'ai très bien connu
votre maman c'était ma meilleure amie
en fait on a vécu ils ont vécu ensemble
elles étaient voisines toutes les deux
et donc elle a appris sa mort par mois
et ça m'a troublé mais d'une façon
incroyable après j'étais l'avoir chez
elle et j'ai trouvé vraiment bizarre
fallu me jouer des morceaux de piano ça
marrant du mal à l'aise je me suis cassé
mais là pour une fois même d'en parler
ça me fait un peu
ça me donne des frissons ce parallèle
entre abraham lincoln le président jfk
le président connaissait c'est alors
kennedy il est mort donc en soi en 61 et
lotissements en 1861 ensuite l'un est
mort dans une lincoln il s'appelait
d'îlots trinité il est mort dans une
kennedy
avec sa plume code non ça continue des
voitures voiture kennedy voitures
rappelées kennedy aussi à l'époque
ensuite il naquit qui est né un monroe
dans le maryland et l'autre il a connu
marilyn monroe
tous les deux avaient donc des tueurs
donc des assassins qui avaient des noms
trois parties donc il ya art parlait ni
oswald et l'autre c'est na nana na na 6
quand j'additionne les lettres des deux
tueurs de détroit non ça fait quinze
lettres et l'unc est parti d'un théâtre
pour aller dans une église
l'autre qui part d'une église pour
s'enfuir dans un théâtre tous les deux
ont eu donc une femme qui ont eu un
avortement enfin quant à porter donc
voilà à s'entendre intervalle tu as été
dit à la fin donc ce truc que j'ai lu
j'ai dit bon alors c'est synchronicité
hasard alors il ya philippe vandel qui
m'a nui non à lucky matin aux médias non
ça c'est mathématique ces probabilités
tu te dois trouver autour de toi bien
100 personnes qui ont vécu les mêmes
trucs les mêmes maladies je dis oui
m'enfin quand même si mais quand même
spiritualité alors les gens évidemment
ils vont pas vers les religions
traditionnelles parce que l'on a un peu
fait le tour mais je vois par exemple
patent le livre de matthieu ricard sur
le bouddhisme il a scotché tout le monde
et il se vend comme des petits pains et
son besoin de saint thurien besoin d'eux
s'ils avaient la vérité ça fait bien
longtemps que les hommes seraient
meilleures qu'il ya là au milan non je
sais pas on a on nous possèdent tout où
on avoue parler de bouquins on à la
bible la torah le séparant les hommes
sans religion n'est pas mieux que dans
quatre ans ces carences affectives
tout part d'une guerre en s'affaissant
il n'y a pas d'amour on élève nos
enfants sans amour à l'arrivée ça crée
des dictateurs non moi je pense que la
solution
à
[Applaudissements]
mais je crois te raconterai tout d'abord
trois ans et demi quatre ans et ont joué
aux criquets dans tous les deux donc tu
vois
le coni profits sur la politique tu
connais aux du tournoi
[Musique]
las
c'est sur quatre étages
c'est quoi un ami de thomas müller
déjoué toutes les places que didier
lockwood et keziah jones
on pourra faire de la musique et l'image
sur quoi on peut chanter anomalies mais
oui bonsoir
[Musique]
ok
faut les faire manger un peu
voulzy il a il a passé c'est que je suis
passé au courant ses colonies de
vacances avec christian vander
ah bon bah oui il a ils arrêtent marées
alors non ils marchaient tous les deux
ils marchaient tous les deux comme ça et
vous sentiez non ouais c'est mon premier
groupe mon premier groupe c'est ma
première sensation de jouer avec
quelqu'un de la musique c'est d'être
collé une vacance avec van der on avait
8 ans 9 ans vous êtes en bretagne magma
on était en bretagne et et on chantait
de ces les chantres de colonies de
vacances vent frais 20 du matin
l'écolo tu connais bon d'accord et moi
je chante d'un seul coup un morceau que
j'avais entendu à la radio c'est
drifting des shadows dans les vendeurs
étaient à côté de moi on avait neuf ans
vander fait à côté de moi j'entends un
accompagnement il fait basse batterie
avec la bouche
alors donc ça faisait d'andes ans dans
l'ain
j'entends à côté moi c'est comme ça
qu'ils ont arrêtés on a fait sur moi
pendant une heure parce que je trouve ça
génial et quoi je chantais le truc à la
guitare électrique avec la bouche et lui
vous êtes fous furieux et ça c'est mon
premier souvenir mais on est sûr mais
qu'on soit l'eau donc on était surtout
qu'à paris que j'en ai reald me chercher
chez moi pour aller à la messe le
dimanche matin
j'ai joué avec lui on a eu peur on a
refondé le magma de d'il ya 25 ans sinon
j'avais à mes avant-hier là c'est pas
toi tu as joué aussi avec des jouets car
big up dans tout ça oui oui bon avec
tout le milieu du jazz quoi tu sais que
tu qu en justice mais cette liste
stonegate j'ai commencé avec dave
brubeck quand j'avais 19 ans cadet
guillaume simard c'est lui qui m'a
invité à là-bas et c'est très moche avec
les mecs qui jouent du violon électrique
en fait en france et mancheste fans
grappelli didier lockwood on dirait que
en direct et catherine lara
d'oublier j'ai envie de continuer quand
même lui qui a révolutionné l'offre il
ya des mois je le dise de pompiers avec
frank zappa présentation de nice blazer
qu'est ce que c'est vous m je vais dire
un taureau ça se fait je ne fais jamais
de bon d'accord ça tombe très mal mais
je suis prêt à prendre ma guitare et à
faire griller quelques accords je peux
faire yvette chef sera certainement pas
moi non mais si toi ça peut être bien
achalandé ya pas de chef dans le nord il
ya un type qui commençait au tissu et
visual c
[Musique]
k
je ferai
[Musique]
non
sur la route
/
sur la peau
sur la route
m -a
et
[Applaudissements]
tous
m
paris
mais
bon
oh
out of my head is broken wings flammes
[Musique]
oh
aulas
il faut dix membres
[Musique]
l'atb féminine de ted of nine
qu'est ce que nous montrent aussi
oyonnax
fortis
[Musique]
tapez sur nos systèmes
l'envié que tout le monde aime le soleil
darde vieux désir super ça est tous un
peu faire le soleil le soleil
alors intelligent de soldats
tap m
aux gens la même couleur ou gentiment
[Musique]
e
ce
les verts
c'est
aimer
richard
e
[Musique]
je sais je suis le mal aimé
j'en
mais ont-ils cherché à savoir
mais joint et pourquoi ce désespoir
caché au fond d'eux
moi car je suis malade
je suis
mais bon
jean mâconnais serait que je mens
mais ont-ils cherché à savoir main
viennent mes joies
pourquoi ce désespoir cacher
si mal aimé je suis là
que je me
montrer mais ont-ils cherché à savoir
[Musique]
allez
c'est vrai chacun son défi
quand tu es jeune
laquelle
mais quand
[Musique]
m
oui
non
tous les sports
alors
hachez le
raté
on l'a fait
elle est en tant que non
m
à hossegor
yeah
audet
oh
[Musique]
o o
m
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé que c'était bienvenue chez
libé à lille pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu